this is the theme the Bijou bismillah
alhamdulillah peace be with you those
are greetings of peace that is what
Muslims used the same greeting that
Jesus greeted his followers with we're
greeting you with that same greeting
here today and there are a lot of
misconceptions about Islam which is the
fastest growing way of life in the world
today yesterday and tomorrow and it will
continue to grow because people are
coming to that realization that life is
short and you know what I in the state
of confusion I don't have the answers to
all the questions that are out there but
Islam provides me for the rational
logical evidences to prove that it's
indeed from the creator of heavens and
earth but there's some misconceptions
out out there about Islam so we've been
invited and you're invited to invite you
to be our guests because with all the
different stereotypes and false
fallacies one of them is that you know
there's a lot of radicalization going on
out there in these places of worship the
mosques that's right so we're gonna take
you on a tour to see is this a mosque
really what's going on in here is there
hate speech going on here is there is a
private bomb-making factory
how does it look inside a mosque where
the people worship where the Muslims
worship let's go ahead and take take you
on a tour come on with Eddie here your
guests your hosts come on so okay so
we're walking around this is where the
Muslims gather now some of us may be a
little bit careful okay so to come in
here and they're not too many around
right now let's go to the right here
come on so you walk in we've got some
pictures on the wall here this is doctor
is it okay some calligraphy come over
here
follow me you're getting a first-hand
look into the house of worship okay we
call this God's house what it means is
that people come here to worship God and
this is the prayer area as you can see
there are no statues okay I'm taking my
shoes off you take your shoes off and
you come on in and this is where people
put their forehead on the ground there
are no pictures you
you walk in some places and you see all
these statues and icons and it just
gives you a creepy kind of feel you know
you should be doing that but this it
gives you a good feeling that you know
what you just come here and you just put
your head on the ground
you just worship God that's it just God
the same way Jesus put his head on the
ground that's what the Muslims do and
the Muslims simply one who submits to
the will of God and you see this area
this is where they gather shoulder the
shoulder foot the foot the black the
white the Chinese the German the Italian
the Polish they all come here as
brothers in humanity and they worship
God they worship just god this is it
there's a prayer let's continue on what
else they got here maybe they got
something else that they don't want us
to see come on okay this is just a
washroom here you got a little shoe area
okay wow this place is very nice and
cleaned come to the lab okay see if we
can find a tour guide okay when you
stand to pray pray as if it's your last
prayer that's deep because you never
know when death will approach so every
Muslim should be praying his prayers his
last prayer young man how are you
peace be with you how are you thank you
I'm good I'm fine hundred I know what's
your name sir hey everyone hey what
would you be so kind as to give us a
little bit of a tour here from from the
mosque all right all right so you know
we're trying to show and they pray a
room that's the prayer room okay okay
have you seen this okay what is this now
this is yeah Mecca all right that's the
I think the 70s is that the first house
of worship built by Abraham
this is it right here do muslims worship
this black box oh no no that's just the
first house of worship that citrus
mosque this is a mosque that's the first
month it is basically the first mosque
yes so harem which is the sacred mosque
it's a masjid yes okay so no worshipping
that you worship the creator of all this
of course definitely that's where people
go for hajj too and that's why we're
Ibrahim and his son Ishmael actually and
they're they both they're the first one
who built that house
there and as you see Mecca this is the
old city of Mecca and this is the
original city of Prophet Muhammad SAW
Lost Island that's where he was born
okay so problem Muhammad he was a
prophet like Jesus Moses Abraham he
wasn't he was the last prophet yeah the
last prophet like he said all prophets
are like brothers born into different
mothers welcome back to the Deen show
we're here in Texas at the Clear Lake
Islamic Center giving you an inside look
at one of the mosques in Houston so we
started out going into the front
corridor and now if you can take a look
this is we showed you where the Muslims
pray where they prostrate there are no
statues pictures any weird things on the
wall
they're just devoting worship to God
just worshiping the one unseen create
tour and in this particular mush it also
you can see they have a nice lounge set
up with Wi-Fi that's right so it's very
beautiful in here this is Sheikh Walid
the Sunnis mustard and this would be
something that if anyone wanted to open
up a mush it this would be something
that one should copy because not only is
a mush it a place where you come and
worship but where communities gather and
they come to get together and get to
know each other so he's seen he has seen
such a success here that the Muslims and
our non-muslim friends brothers in
humanity are welcome to come in it can
be a part of this that now they know
each other better because they sit
around and they talk and they hang out
instead of going out to the coffee shops
and the kids getting in trouble you have
a playground here the kids can play in
the playground we showed you two
playground and you also have this very
nice atmosphere here a nice ambience
they show different movies documentaries
have different lectures it's beautiful
let's go meet some of somes come on
there's some people gathering over here
by some beautiful paintings so
still in the mosque the Masjid and you
can see now I wish we can find the the
artists who you know that that'd be a
nice thing to find the artists who who
were actually painted these wonderful
paintings oh oh he's here
hey I'm the LA all thanks to God how are
you sir what's your name as that
abolished as that abolish now you're the
one responsible for these beautiful this
beautiful artwork here all made with my
hands
nice alright ma sha la can can you tell
us now is the Arabic calligraphy can you
tell us now define what are these say
and what are some of the meanings here
behind them okay first of all all of
them except one are a present to the
mosque I did them and give it to the
mosque as a present this one here is a
labovick related my own uncle Allah
basically he that mine no clue which
means by reminding yourself by God by
mentioning God in your heart your heart
which is agitated calms down and this is
the beauty of remembering heart
remembering God this one here is the
saying of sayyidna musa we said rubbish
Sharlee sadly were simply Emery while
dr. Melissa knee of call calling this is
one of the greatest prayers are like
from the Quran which she says God opened
my heart make it easy for me make me
alik eloquent so that they understand
what I say this one here what as a moba
huble elijah me and voila lava rock a
tasimu bihabli llahi me and means all of
you muslims unite and attach yourself to
the Rope of God
this is how you get the strength when
you are united you are strong when you
are divided you are weak and can be
conquered this one here is the English
translation here but I read Arabic here
may I be were on my entire rasulallah
you're the Prophet Muhammad I sacrifice
my mother and my father for you I
painted that when they attacked the
Prophet Muhammad by the cartoonists and
this is his love is in our heart and you
can see the heart here and we give it to
him now let me ask you this
you know for some people to comprehend
that it's it's very difficult but when
you name you mentioned Moses there and
we also people now they know that we as
Muslims some might don't know for those
that don't that we love Jesus so anyone
who is it true that anyone who insulted
Jesus Moses Abraham that would be an
insult to Muslims also because their
beloved to our hearts too is that right
this is what in the Quran all of them
are equal in the eyes of God and there
was a story when the Prophet was in
Medina and a Muslim tried to insult a
Jew there because they were living
together there about Moses he said no
you are absolutely wrong
he is my brother he is as respected as I
am Moses ya Muslim ok so we love knows
we love one of all the prophets of
Muhammad yeah they are equal equal in
other eyes their equals to Muhammad
especially but the rank is a little bit
different yes but there are all gods or
from God yes to human being beautiful
let's continue please ok this one here
from the Quran also bubble Walid any
asana means take care of your parents
take care of your parents right take
care of your parents and this is an
essential part we should really realize
now they were
they give you all what they had
sincerely without expecting anything
unconditional of yes so this is what I
think is a valuable quotation from the
Quran yes now I like this one here this
one is really profound here because you
have a boat here it says forever what is
that a Bentley or a Rolls Royce you got
some gambling going on you know the
gamble is not allowed in Islam okay you
got some drinking you got some partying
going on here
money and some would say that's like
bling bling in modern terms you know and
you got some is that the the the the
devil The Satanic forces wine what's
going on with this what inspired me to
know this was Enron and when I when I am
from Houston so I lived that scandal of
everyone and that what is reminds us in
the Quran means you keep collecting
things until you die this is the the the
weakness of the human being and God
reminds us that one day will die and
that's why I made this painting to show
the indulgence of things and the
injustice because you cannot collect all
this money without injustice and then
self pleasures and that's why eventually
see he's rich he's the stock market he
has real estate he has money money and a
house and on his boat he write forever
like he's gonna live forever and ever
forever and and he is guided by the
devil to do this to do the the sins the
sins so you got that could be drugs
alcohol
yes womanizing correct gambling gambling
and then he dies and then it's done it's
done does he take any of this with him
that's why he said here is written from
the Quran also yes what writing here man
Malea my money did not prevent me from
dying I'm not going to live forever he
couldn't buy his way out of the grave
right and did not prolong his life one
second when his time comes it's done and
then he will be punished not only in the
hereafter but also I'll in grief here is
the snake and the crocodile here the
snake and crocodile are a symbol for the
punishment you get in indicating the
grave is if you are good you'll be
rewarded your little grave would be
lighted angels will accompany you say
you're not alone we are with you if you
are did bad things then you will be
punished in the grave and and kill you
day of judgment this is really beautiful
tell us for our brothers in humanity
than not yet Muslims because we really
want them to understand us because Islam
today is misunderstood so tell us would
you if some of our brothers from in
humanity came in and wanted to see some
of your artwork see the mosque are they
welcome or does Islam teach you to hate
those who are not Muslim Islam is based
on love peace and justice and the world
Islam is peace but half of it is peace
and justice is the you know this man is
didn't do justice for the world you have
to be just yourself your family your
society to the world and that's Islam
anyone wants to come to the mosque and
see this is welcome the mosque is anyone
anyone any religion money or no religion
yes come in you know it's it's God's
house it's not my house it's God's house
it's God's house yes and he welcomes all
his people who created oh may create it
when you hear a couple more questions
just before because you have I'm
definitely I mean we're very impressed
with this
and a person such as yourself who's over
the years gained so much experience and
when you see a lot of the misconceptions
out there people talking about Islam
like it's something that's barbaric that
you know islam teaches terrorism and
radicalization of the youth does this
sat in your heart what do you how do you
respond to this
that really saddens my heart but I have
to blame also the Muslims for not
portraying Islam the right way some bad
apples destroyed the whole crop yes and
I really people should not look at these
bad apples look at Islam look at the
history of Islam learn that's why I I
published a book called Islam in the
eyes of an artist showing how Islam is
beautiful how Islam is peaceful how high
level of meditation and elevation of the
soul in Islam in all in paintings and
transit and the English explanation next
to it
so really Aslam needs a lot and we
harvest we should educate people and
people should seek knowledge ignorance
is the best enemy to anyone that's right
ignorance is the best enemy to anyone so
we need to clear up all this confusion
by getting ourselves educated and come
visit here at chez Khaled's the Sunnis
Masjid here in the Clear Lake Islamic
Center doctor is that it yes and he'll
give you a tour of some of his beautiful
paintings and if you have any other
questions you know stop by and visit us
here that's right come and visit the
Muslims come and learn directly from the
Muslims and get to know your
neighborhood Muslims those who have
consciously submitted to one God and
that's how we get peace and we wish you
peace thank you very much thank you for
visiting us we were very rewarded by
your vist thank you very much thank
you Salam alaikum
and if we're gonna worship something I
figured I might as well worship the
Creator instead of any of the creations
now in upon investigating the villages I
remember finding out the meaning of what
Islam is what most limits those who
surrender their self to God is a Muslim
those who cemento submit to God God's
will daizen Islam was pure it was just
you just pray to God your Creator
there's another young man here and I
think yesterday we were going and having
a tour and we want to continue we're
almost done here Sheikh Ibrahim how are
you yeah I wasn't expecting that you're
also one of the Imams here is some the
administrator also for the Clear Lake
Islamic Centre yes yeah now now we saw
the present we got to see the the prayer
area you know one interesting thing is
there's there's no statues there's no
pictures what what's going on here I
well basically statues and images in
Islam are not permitted and it is since
the early days of Islam when the Prophet
Muhammad peace be upon him
you know destroyed all these statues
that were around the Kaaba so that was
something that was forbidden and it is
like taking the religion back to the era
of Abraham he's the first one who
destroyed the statue so definitely we
will not have him in our message it and
not any message it you in in the whole
world will have any statues it's all
about the worship of the one god the one
God Allah the same God that Jesus
worship Jesus would have broke some
statues to no statues and we're not
talking promoting breaking statues out
there but we're just as similar as I
symbolizing the the worship of the the
one got pure monotheism this is what
Islam is based on absolutely absolutely
Jesus himself in the Bible said that you
should worship only one God the God in
heaven that that is the only God that
deserves to be worshipped and actually I
heard in a lot of your interviews that
people translate the word Allah into the
only one through God that's a
description Allah is the only one
through god but allah also means the
worshipped one that is basically the
meaning of the word Allah he is the
worshipped one meaning you know he's the
only one who deserves to be worshipped
and that's even embedded in the meaning
of Allah now you got to learn a little
bit also more about Islam and the key
pillar only worship the cradle let's
continue walking around this house of
worship
as we said yesterday this is a community
hall and it is it is set up in such a
way where it is a family friendly
environment where families can come and
actually we have everything for all the
family here we made it where the sisters
can enjoy themselves there so you
separate here you have the men with the
men the women with the women to make
them feel more comfortable and also if a
family like a father you know peer
parents and their children can sit
around and you know discuss something
and you know eat something together we
have the provision for the boys with the
boys the woman with the women yes
definitely I mean it may sound that you
know we're it's it's like society we're
dealing with society with all its you
know factions and all its elements so
basically any people can come enjoy
themselves in this in this facility
Muslims non-muslims and they can come
and just you know enjoy you know
socializing with Muslims in this
facility in such a way that it is not
even about religion it's about
neighborhood and being friendly to your
neighbors and being welcoming and that's
that's the attitude that we have in this
place actually okay so what else do we
have here now just like I told you we
haven't you know we saw the playground
yesterday right it's right did we see it
do we see it
Wow Subhan Allah now this now this is a
must [ __ ] now some people might think
like what are you doing you got a like a
playpen here there's not a playpen it's
like a mega-size play center in the mus
[ __ ] and hey but what if someone a
that's and someone says man this is some
kind of bid ah no it's not actually this
is very much encouraged by the spirit of
Islam you know you want to attract the
kids to come in here you know they go to
McDonald's and what happens at
McDonald's they eat unhealthy food I'm
not against McDonald's but that's the
reality is that they you know so we
bring them here for a healthy
environment you know their parents can
cook their food and they can come and
eat it here the children can play like
we have two kids here playing it's at a
time where not many kids are in the
message but yeah it's to attract those
kids and to have him attached to the
message and you know see their parents
go to a prayer and come play here and
then you know it's there is something
where you know attached they you know
connect kids to it fun you know we're
going to the message we're going to the
mosque to have fun which is very good
and later on they'll find out that you
know they're loving the place of worship
and they know the purpose of it more so
than just having fun although having fun
is nothing wrong with it so yeah this is
amazing this is amazing about this when
I was yes this is amazing so we want to
inspire you we want to really motivate
people who are thinking about making a
must [ __ ] that they incorporate this
into the Masjid this is wonderful
so what else I heard you actually you
got a we get Get Fit a fitness a fitness
center in the mosque amazing so now if
you got need some you know greasy
biryani or you know some hamburgers you
shouldn't be eating you know with all
the greasy stuff and you you you want to
change your eating pattern healthy and
now you want to look good and feel good
you know the best way is to make the
salat you know that's that food for the
soul
now you got some training for the body
tell us what thought process went behind
this to make this happen well basically
this is something that has Mehcad ream
you know a lot of especially the the
sisters who come to the Masjid you know
they want to have a place where they can
do it alone you know without any male
interaction and they can just come and
feel comfortable so we found that this I
mean the message can provide this for
the sisters and basically you know we
have it where it's four days for the
sisters three days for the brothers and
they can come and enjoy them themselves
in a way where you know Fitness is is
something that is recommended in Islam
you have to be fit actually and you know
like you said you know pray or can do so
much but they cannot really shed the fat
that you have so we add to it something
that Allah has blessed us with which is
you know to be active and to be fit and
find ways to you know burn these
calories so amazing amazing tell us now
hamdulillah all praises to God to Allah
and so a we got that out of the way that
our brothers in humanity are welcome
here they're not yet Muslims they can
come in here anytime I'm there that yeah
we're open for all the you know all the
neighborhood anyone can come here and
actually we've had many of our neighbors
come here and you know enjoy the you
know the environment and use the
facility we had students who would come
and study we had faith groups and we
we've arranged actually interfaith
activities with churches in the
neighborhood that they can use the
facility and we can go also there and
use their facility so this is like
that's how it is in America you know we
have to work together we have to live
together and just like you have a now
you know a Christian neighbor that
Christian neighbor can come to you or a
place of worship and see how you see
what you do actually in your at most
intimate moments with a loss of hanataro
with your Creator for those people that
try to you know depict Islam is
something that is out there to get you
it's the other
it's about you know creating mischief
here in America and you know it's like
the boogeyman is coming to get you here
terrorism Muslim what do you have to say
to those people who are confused about
Islam well there are so much that you
can say but I think the best way is to
reach out to the people and and do
rather than say and just show them you
know by example come and see us and see
what we do we're part of you were part
of the fabric of American Muslims are
and the integral an integral part of
America you know they're they're really
good citizens and they have you know
contributed to this society in so many
ways and unfortunately when they
contribute to the society they are known
by their individuals but their Muslim
and their faith encourages them to be
good to the society and to be productive
productive so what I say is not
everything you hear in the media is you
have to really be critical
in what you hear in the media and you
know think for yourself and go visit
your neighbor the Muslim neighbor and
ask him if that's true and they will
show you a hospitality they will show
you come to our places of worship to
social gatherings and you will see who
we are for what we are exactly yes yes
that is excellent tell us the last point
I want to ask you is for the Muslims now
we want this to be an example of what a
mush it can be it's not just restricted
to the five daily prayers that bringing
community together the way you guys have
you got a gym here you got a playground
for the kids instead of the kids going
to Starbucks or this cafe that cafe and
getting in trouble out there
you know they come and they attach their
heart to the house of God to the house
of Allah but sometimes you have you know
those you have some people and we want
to soften their hearts to some of the
people that don't get the youth involved
and they sometimes close this door and
make it difficult for the youth to be
involved in to prosper and to grow like
you guys have what advice do you have
for those well you know to begin with
this you know when we started here as a
Muslim community in America we were like
immigrant families who came here
and we kind of like did not change the
mentality that we came with and we just
wanted our places of worship the same
way we used to have him back back home
and whatever country we came from and
this is not really healthy and it's not
really even you know productive in
society like America it's a very
fast-growing society and youth they have
so much exposure to other things so you
have to really be competitive with
whatever they're out there that is
attracting our youth and how are you
those are our children and and we seeing
we see them I mean be they Muslim
Christian or Jews we have the same
problem all these faith groups have the
same problem with the youth that they're
running away from religion and we want
them to really come back to religion and
see that there are certain things that
you can incorporate in your places of
worship that attract the youth and
there's nothing wrong with them and you
can be competitive you can show them the
better way of life the better
alternative to whatever is out there
because whatever is out there is there
to make money and they don't really care
about you know the mental health of your
child the physical health of your child
in a place like this we care about this
social health mental health and physical
health and religious and spiritual
health and so what I say is we have to
really change that mentality and start
learning more from our youth what they
really want and exactly this is the
product of the youthful thinking of the
leadership in this community you know
luckily the Sunni mashallah he has a
really great you know insight and it's
because he's been in contact with so
many a youth that he is able to really
you know realize the things in the dream
that they have so this is just part of
the solution we're trying to solve this
and we advise our brothers everywhere
those who built their massage it please
don't pay so much attention to just
decorating your message rather than
making it functional with great
facilities that you know help and serve
and
here or to every member of the family
and every member of the society actually
that's amazing don't spend all the time
arguing about the minaret how big it's
gonna be 50 feet third or the dome this
design that design you know broaden your
mind open your mind and do some of the
things we're giving you an example here
let the uncles we call them work with
the youth work together so we can grow
together exactly well that's I mean one
dome may cost about a hundred thousand
dollars to make with a hundred thousand
dollars you can make you know a gym
double this size you know where the
youth can say well it's better than the
dome I can't really do anything with the
dome I can't climb it but I can do
something with this here so you're
really putting your money in a good full
use I mean an useful purpose yes thank
you very much peace be with you thank
you so much oh my dear lord I thank you
for coming here we appreciate your your
efforts thank you thank you I'm doula
thank you